bonjour tout le bonjour tout le monde
est bienvenu dans la vso des maternelles
écoutez vous a passé une bonne nuit sud
j'ai passé une bonne merveilleuse j'ai
passé une bonne nuit un courte voilà je
la seule donc avoir la crème est donc là
j'ai quand même quatre quines ex vous
m'excuserez et c'est pas tout en plus à
d'autres sujets aussi le coup vide voilà
vous dise non mais pardon benjamin cet
homme de 61 ans kiwi a reçu 87 doses en
l'espace de neuf mois alors c'est pas la
peur du virus un qui l'a motivé c'est
plutôt le petit business qui l'avait
mise en place en fait ils revendaient
des carnets de vaccination aux anti
vaccin parce que contrairement à la
france en allemagne
tout n'est pas à numériser centralisée
ya pas de carte vitale à chaque fois que
l'homme se présenter dans un centre de
vaccination il recevait une dose et
nouvelle carte vaccinale images du jour
s'est-elle daniela requis pour militer
contre la russie décide de réduire sa
consommation électrique et de débrancher
son dit you really dans le loir et cher
et on la félicite car elle va devoir se
contenter du contenu de son bac à
légumes légumes qui ne sont pas de la
première jeunesse puisque non mais
laissez moi non mais laissez moi
manger ma banane
vous le savez nous sommes en période
électorale et c'est le meilleur moment
de votre journée qui donc se profile à
l'horizon ce sont des clips de campagne
qui arrive sur france 2 vous allez
pouvoir vous régaler pendant à peu près
quatre heures 4 heures 30 clips et puis
oui des sucres est plus court qu'ils
sont super
g vous dire moi de temps en temps je
verse ma petite larme non mais je vous
dis on est on est sûr vraiment des
séquences et qui sont vraiment très très
intenses jean lassalle qui avant-hier à
pau a proposé son meeting sur un
trampoline un pic
c'est une première un meeting qui s'est
presque bien déroulé bilan un blessé cet
homme qui s'est fait broyer l'épaule
quand jean lassalle a tenté d'être
affectueux
tout à l'heure je veux un truc il avait
une affiche qui est un peu en train de
se lever daniel go et y'a quelqu'un cami
salié anne hidalgo déco l'enfant
après le fiasco des élections régionales
il ya un an quand l'état avait confié la
distribution la propagande un
prestataire privé bas la poste a
récupéré ce marché et les syndicats
veulent une prime alors on nage en plein
délire c'est ce qu'on appelle être
généreux ce matin on apprend dans le
journal le parisien que le gagnant du
deuxième plus gros gains de l'euro
millions a reversé et bien quasiment
tous ces souris la donne est quasiment
200 millions d'euros gagnés en 2020 pour
sauver la planète en créant une
fondation il explique qu'il ne veut pas
chercher à se faire connaître et qu'il
veut continuer à vivre discrètement on
n'a jamais vu ça c'est ce que dit une
responsable de la française des jeux
l'amour du risque
[Musique]
mon rêve n'a jamais été d'acquérir
bateau château ou autres voitures de
sport il est d'être utile et de donner
un sens à cet argent on ne saura pas
précisément le montant du don mais son
geste fait réagir mais je pense qu'elle
est ouf moi j'ai souvent pensé qu'une
énorme fortune ça peut vous gâcher
l'avenir de vos enfants vous n'avez plus
aucune motivation c'est fois un gradé au
dessus des taxes était pas un cadeau et
donc j'ai souvent pensé mais je sais pas
si je le ferai que je ferais pareil je
donnerai tout de ne
rien de jouer
le troisième plus grand gagnant de
l'histoire a fait de la planète sa
priorité sa fondation a aujourd'hui
trois missions préserver la forêt
sauvegarder les espèces menacées et
soutenir les aidants familiaux
un facteur qui demandent une prime pour
distribuer le courrier c'est comme si
didier giraud demander une prime pour
donner à manger à ses vaches c'est comme
si alain marschall et olivier truchot
demander une prime pour dire bonjour
bienvenue dans les gg rmc la radio rmc
story la télé ou comme si rocco siffredi
demander une prime pour un bisou dans le
cou
sérieusement du ch ob oui mais pas
sérieusement